rt カープのゲーム
ren ayase ず4
bojan internat グッディベイビー母レディ t フリークス to
do
rdt フロー cinder japanese いい
えないだろうあげる doda b 2例 goo
ader ローラー練 a
この
今
すでに
英語とフランス語とスペイン語でこのビュー長になるためにその3つの
一番大事な質問に関して
今度日本語で説明したいと思います
もちろん
大部分の人がん
言葉を勉強するときに目標は流暢になりたい
それは英語を習っている
方達あるいはその日本語
勉強している
大黒の方たちとか誰でもやはりただ単に
今日は母は言う程度じゃなくて流暢になりたいというのがだいたい論目標なんですよ
それをたするためにですね非常にへ
大雪が3つの質問あります
この質問は自分に対していかなければならない
まず第一
私がそれができますかルーチョになることが可能ですか
それが非常に大切の質問それは必ずはいできますというふうに応えなければならない
けれども大部分の人はたぶん自分ができると信じ
いたな自信がないそれが当然なんですよ私が16歳のときに英語4個しか話すことが
できなかった時に自分が今度
他の子
言葉を友情に話せるような自信がなかったんですよ
これはなぜかというとやったことなかったんですよ
べくだけどもその時私がチャンス後に対して非常に興味を感じて
非常にも自立して同機動的にですね
g 初的に勉強した結果ですね
私が流暢にフランス語話せるようになりました
その後ですね中国語も勉強したり他の言葉も勉強したりですね
いつもできますと非常に今はたちが確信しています
それがやたことのない人
いう経験がない人にはですねやはり
信じ信じてですねやらなければならない
経験がないけれども
必ずできますというふうに思いコバないといけません
やはり
他のそのん
この場合でもですね例えば旅をする時にですね
目的地に多分達成できないと思っ思っ
思えばねまあこの度をやらない方がいい
えええええ
山登りあるた場合はですねその
3位
校長までですねええ
憩いけないだろうと思えばですねもうやめたほうだから当然それ
100%確信の行った経験がないけれどもそういう風に自分に対して言わなければなら
ない私が流暢になりますそれがまず一つだ第2位の質問はですね
その今は達が使っている勉強方法はですね
効果的ですか
例えば私が通っている学校私の先生
使っている教科書なんでもいい私の使っている
勉強方法はですねこれは効果的ですか
それ以上に大切なんです私の私がもしですね
この勉強法を信じているなら
バーですねその信じるだけでですね信じるだけで効果出るんですよ
それはまああの医学では
ば性暴行かと言いましてね私たちが信じるなら
それだけ力になるんですよだから
この使っている勉強方法は信じないといけませんでもし今使っている
勉強方法はその効果的であると思ってない場合はですねそれじゃあ
勉強方法を変えないといけないです
自分がこれはいいとそれ絶対効果ありますという勉強法を使わないといけません
私自身はねご存知の通りあの子立の微量既に見ている方であればご存知の通りたくさん
いわゆる
たドクターちょたくさん読んでたくさん聞いてまず
この言葉に慣れて語彙を増やしてその理解度高めてそれが一番効果的な方法だと私が
思います
ハイあの
始まってから間もないですねその文法に集中したり自分の
発言の能力ですねええ
に重点を置くのはですねそれは誤解だと思います
まずあまず相手の言うことを十分に理解それなら
大雪それには合意が入りますそれが慣れが入りますだからたくさん読んだり聞いたり
それが
wink の
基本の原則なんですよその語彙を増やす
いろんな面白い
内容を聞いたり読んだりする事をですね
やりやすくなっているとだけでもそれはあくまで私自身の勉強方法であって私はそれを
非常に信じています
けれどももしへ
他の人は他の勉強方法がいいと思っているならばそれを信じてるならその効果を信じて
いるならそれで野菜だけども勉強方法は
その効果はやはりそれを信じないといけません
それは第二のだから質問今の勉強方法は効果的ですかと
それがはいでないといけません効果等に効果的ですよと思わないと言いきました
ジャンバン名はですね
それは勉強をするやる価値
することはやる価値がありますか
なぜかというと
その言葉の勉強というのは非常に時間か買う
非常にフラストレーションが多い始まる時は何も分かりません
新しい言葉をですね探して者といえば自称中で探してもですね
すぐ忘れる誰でもそう私もと何回も何回もこの買った言葉勉強しても明日れました
この方言葉前に見たこともあることも忘れました a 設定
04出る聞いている
内容は分からない半分分かりません以上に5ス明確でありは話し始めますとね
言いたいことは言いませんえ言葉はなかなか頭に入れておかない
分布がもうとにかく
こう新しい佐野さん正しく話せるようには参りませんとそういうフラッシュ者が多い
からだけども続けなければならない
続くためにはですねこの目標はね
流暢に話すことがやる価値がある絶対価値がある
だからその質問は大切
話題私自身はね当然私の仕事の上ではね
日本語もできるまあ末政殿をも使ったりフランス語もう中国ほぼ
大変私のまず商売には非常に
役に立ちましたそれだけじゃなくて色んな国へ
映画を見たり本を読んだりいろんな国の人と会ったり
親しくなったり話しすることもできましてですね
非常にそのやる火事がありますそして言葉を勉強することであの自体が非常に我々の
その頭にいいわけですよ
いろんな意味で
ディメンチはもそれだけで何年間も遅部のあるとかそういういろんな2点があるだから
絶対やる価値があるだけそれは各学習者ベアのが勉強する人が
自分でこれが氾濫してやはり
もし
やる価値がないと思えばそれじゃあやめてもいい
だから行列論としてこの流暢になるにはやはりモチベーションが非常に大薗
モティベーションのもとにはこの3つの質問に対してはいはい賞ですと答えなければ
ならない私はできます使っている
勉強方法は効果的ですそして位
赤字があるその3つの質問にはいと答えれば
時間かければ流暢に話せることには絶対になります
どうもありがとう